planetary importance purpose for silence
and sartorial significance these are all
the elements of andor's first season
that may have blown by you at light
speed
during this conversation with Luth and
Rael and Andor episode 4 Cassian Andor
describes his time as a conscripted
soldier in the Imperial military he says
that when he was 16 after being released
from prison he was sent to fight on a
planet called mimban Lutheran calls out
several lies in his story but
acknowledges that Cassian did spend time
on the mud soaked Planet before running
away if you've seen solo a Star Wars
story you'll likely remember mimban it's
the same drab world that the young
harness shown fighting on early in the
film in the greater Star Wars Canon
mimban has been valued for its Rich
natural resources as a result has been
fought over many times by different
factions including drawing the Clone
Wars while cassia may not have spent as
long on the muddy Planet as he initially
claims it's safe to assume that his
tenure there was still horrific if Han
Solo's own experiences on mimbana any
indication there's very little joy to be
found when serving the Empire there
the first Andor scene set at the
Imperial Security Bureau shows a meeting
among senior staff discussing Rebel
status across the Galaxy at the start of
the scene one officer is heard
describing circumstances in the ryloth
sector warning that extra funds may be
needed in the near future to combat
anti-imperial activity Die Hard Star
Wars fans will surely know Rye love and
it's penchant for Rebellion ryloth has a
long and dark history of Oppression
stretching Back to Before the days of
the Clone Wars once the Empire Rose to
power the system was subjugated even
further but said citizens familiarity
with tyrannical regimes made it
difficult to control entirely Star Wars
Rebels details the actions of the free
weilath movement a resistance effort led
by the charismatic charm syndullah and
supported at different times by larger
sects of the alliance to restore the
Republic given the time period in which
Andor is set it makes sense that ryloth
will be a particularly unstable region
for his Imperial rulers to deal with
mentioning the planet's pretty action
for Rebellion it's a nice touch and a
great way to show the nature of the ISB
right out of the gate
another Mata briefly mentioned during
the first Imperial Security Bureau scene
in Andor is the increase in Supply
shipments to scarif of course that's
where the plans for the Death Star were
being held in Rogue one ending the ISB
scene with this subtly dark line sets
the tone for the Empire's activity at
this point in the Star Wars timeline but
it's also strikingly relevant to
cassian's personal story scarif is a
place where Cassian Andor dies it's the
end of his long fight against oppression
in the Galaxy the Battle of scarif will
likely hang over the audience's head for
the entirety of the show as anyone
watching will be intimately familiar
with what befalls him there because of
that dramatic irony and or functions in
part as a tragic Saga but of course
kashian has a long way to go before he
gets to scarif and he makes some big
plays against the empire along the way
when Cassian gets dropped off by
Lutheran to join other rebels in Andor
episode 4 he's told to pick a new name
it's a smart move given all the
commotion he causes on ferrics and is
surely not his first or last occasion
working under an alias think of a name
think of a name for yourself
Clem if you weren't paying close
attention to the earlier episodes the
significance of this Choice might fly
right by you a good deal of time is
spent on cassian's adoptive mother Marva
in the early episodes of Andor but he
also had an adoptive father who's shown
with Marva in flashbacks that character
played by Gary Beadle is named Clem in
another conversation between Lutheran
and Cassian is also revealed that Clem
was executed by imperial agents when
Cassian was still young with all that in
mind his choice of an alias is
particularly significant not only is he
paying tribute to his late father but
he's doing so while fighting against a
regime that killed him before leaving
Cassian to return to Coruscant Luth then
gives him a gift a down payment the item
is a blue cliver crystal necklace which
has multiple layers of significance on
the most basic level the necklace
represents an Attunement to the force
which has always been a rallying cry for
the Rebel Alliance also I've noticed
that Jin erso has a similar kyber
necklace in Rogue one given that she and
Cassian and share the final days
together it's poignant that he also gets
one and of course Kaiba is a huge plot
device and the greatest story of Rogue
one as it's a power source behind the
death star's super laser this makes
Lutheran's gift somewhat Grim as it
foreshadows the way Cassian will
ultimately meet his end beyond all that
though Lutheran's gift holds extra
significance for those well versed in
the more obscure corners of the old Star
Wars Canon Luth then calls a necklace a
kuati Signet referencing the planet of
kuat which was hugely important in the
formation of the Republic in the now
defunct Star Wars Legends timeline to
make things even more interesting
Lutheran says that the Signet has a
special meaning the ancient world
celebrates the uprising against the
rakatan Invaders
that's a deep deep cut into the
franchise's far-flung past drawing the
era before the Jedi and the Sith much of
the Galaxy was conquered by the
villainous for cartons and the legends
lore now it seems that's Canon once
again
Loof and rael's strange shop of
historical trinkets is home to many
hidden Easter eggs and not all of them
are references to the Star Wars Universe
in particular the gallery features a
couple of subtle nods to the Indiana
Jones movies which also owe their
existence to George Lucas in episode 4
indeed's whip can be seen frozen in
carbonite this is clearly a reference to
how Harrison Ford who's played Indiana
Jones in every film was also frozen in
carbonite while portraying Han Solo and
The Empire Strikes Back in episode 5
there's an even more obscure in the
Easter egg hiding in the final scene
Luth then is shown tuning in to some
Rebel radio frequencies in the back room
of the gallery and on a shelf behind him
you can see two stones with distinct
markings these are replicas of the
Sankara Stones which play a major role
in the plot of the Temple of Doom it's
also worth noting that the Sankara
stones are shelved next to what appears
to be a pair with Jedi and Sith
holocrons however these artifacts are
much larger than the ones usually seen
in Star Wars so it's include exactly
what their nature or purpose is
regardless they're another fun inclusion
the very end of Andor episode 6 gives
viewers a proper look into the Imperial
Senate a part of the Star Wars universe
that's frequently been mentioned but
rarely seen that's largely because the
Senate is fully dissolved by Emperor
Palpatine at the beginning of a new hope
following the completion of the Death
Star in Andor however the Imperial
Senate is still active in the brief
scene the Senate appears to be much the
same as it is in the prequel era the
disc shaped platforms for each
delegation the echoing Acoustics and the
overall look and feel of the Senate
chamber are pretty much the same as they
are in The Phantom Menace attack of the
Clones and Revenge of the Sith of course
a Decor has changed a bit with new pods
now emblazoned with the Imperial logo
watching mon mothma attempt to push
humanitarian agendas in this void of the
touch disinterest is bound to conjure
memories of Padme Amidala's own time in
the Senate like her mothma seems to be
struggling against the established
system
throughout and or season 1 mon mothma
makes numerous references to Gorman a
major planet within the Empire much of
her work in the Senate to join the
aldani operation involves the Gormans
who are suffering because of trade
routes being blocked by their Imperial
overlords mothma is pushing for Aid and
lifted restrictions on the Gormans
however those who have seen Star Wars
Rebels will know that things only get
worse for them several years later in
the timeline a terrible crime is
committed on Gorman a violent attack
from the Empire known as the Gorman
Massacre drawing a peaceful protest
against Imperial oppression soldiers
opened fire on innocent civilians
killing many the repercussions of this
event were numerous Chief among them mon
mothma herself publicly decrying Emperor
Palpatine's violent regime and the evil
perpetuated under his rule her
subsequent departure from the Senate
became a lightning rod moment for the
Rebel Alliance given that Gorman is so
Central to mothma's eventual departure
from the Imperial Senate it seems only
fitting that should still be fighting
for the planet years earlier not only
does this detail add Dimension to her
conviction but it also connects Andor to
the events of Star Wars Rebels in an
effective way
when we return to the Imperial Security
Bureau at the beginning of Andor episode
7 there's a familiar face waiting
addressing Deirdre Miro and her peers as
none other than wolf you Lauren a
veteran of the Clone Wars and the
high-ranking Imperial official whose
history goes back as far as the
franchise itself in numerous episodes of
Star Wars the Clone Wars you Laren makes
appearances as one of the Republic's
most respected amaros he frequently
works with Anakin Skywalker and the
clone troopers of the 501st
participating in many different
campaigns as a strategist and military
leader after the end of the war you
Lauren remains loyal to the Empire
working as a leader in both the ISB and
the naval intelligence agency it might
be tough for some to understand how a
loyal Ally of the Jedi became one of the
most powerful agents in Palpatine's
regime but to Laren leaves no doubts
among those who serve under him as to
his ruthless nature his first canonical
appearance in the franchise actually
takes place in the original Star Wars as
he's present at the Imperial meeting at
which Darth Vader uses the force to
choke for the first time on screen you
Lauren's appearance of the ISB in Andor
speaks to how seriously the Empire is
starting to take the rebellion in Star
Wars Rebels and a number of novels and
comic books you Laren fights tirelessly
to root out sedition even working
closely with grand Admiral thrawn
Luther rails shop of curios and
Antiquities is a never-ending source of
Easter eggs in Andor in addition to the
artifacts glimpsed in early episodes
episode 7 features a Jedi Relic that
should be of special interest to
longtime fans well Lou Finn discusses
The Heist and aldani with mon mothma a
Jedi Temple guard Mass can be seen on
display in the background one of the
most enigmatic sects within the Jedi
Order the temple guards were sworn
Protectors of the Jedi's Home Secrets
and traditions until the temple was
sucked by Darth Vader and his clone
troopers since Lutheran Shoppers on
Coruscant it's not hard to imagine how
he might have acquired such an item
especially given his involvement in the
Jedi sympathizing Rebellion
one of the more interesting bits of lore
in Andor episode 7 comes from mon mothma
who describes her work for the
separatist coalition to her old friend
and potential ally Tay Kolmar I'm a
polite sometimes indecisive senator who
spends it is fighting and failing to
protect separatist do-gooders obviously
the separatists a galactic faction
builds up and empowered from the Shadows
by Darth Sidious and Count Dooku were
the enemies of the Republic during the
Clone Wars you'd think that their
defeats at the end of the war would mean
their eradication from the political
sphere but it seems that things aren't
that simple the truth is many planets
existed or wish to exist Beyond Republic
rule long before the Clone Wars ever
broke out and with the Empire presenting
a far harsher and more violent regime it
makes sense that there would continue to
be tension with those systems we don't
have a lot of details about the
non-rebel work Monmouth has been doing
but it seems clear that her humanitarian
Pursuits are directly tied to her more
seditious interests separatist groups
were already disgruntled before the
Empire came to power would make great
allies to the Rebellion there's also the
possibility that more people have
aligned with the separatists labeled in
the years since the war ended using its
name recognition as a marker of their
own desire for Independence
the seventh episode of Andor finally
shows exactly what happened to cassian's
adoptive father Clem in the wake of the
Empire's rise soldiers came to fairwigs
to assert the new regime's rule while
trying to stop other locals from
starting a fight with the Imperials Clem
was wrongfully arrested and sentenced to
hang in the Town Square his death
clearly still haunts both Cassian and
Marva perhaps the most interesting thing
about this scene is that while the
Imperial officer is clearly wearing the
new regime's colors the soldiers are
clone troopers not Stormtroopers this
tells us that the flashback takes place
in the very very early days of the
Empire before non-clone recruits replace
the Grand Army of the Republic Star Wars
a bad batch explores this era in great
detail showing how Stormtroopers became
the norm in Palpatine's military clearly
the citizens of ferricks aren't too
happy with the New Order of things as
the whole squabble with Clem starts when
one man shouts
along with Cassian Andor himself one of
the most beloved characters from Rogue
one is is k2so the reprogrammed Imperial
military Droid voiced by Alan tudek
equally snarky and capable K2 plays a
major role in the mission to obtain the
Death Star plans and he has a lot of
history with Cassian specifically anyone
looking for k2so's return may feel
frustrated at the end of Andor episode 7
which features a different Droid of the
exact same make and model viewers might
think they're seeing k2so when the Droid
in question is quickly revealed to be a
much different and more vicious specimen
to be fair head writer Tony Gilroy told
The Hollywood Reporter before Andor even
premiered that we wouldn't be meeting
k2so for a while we're still five years
out from the events of Rogue one so
there's a long way yet to go
less than Easter egg than a full-on
cameo appearance Forest Whitaker returns
to Star Wars in the 8th and 11th
episodes of Andor that's unpredictable
Rebel leader saw Guerrero well known for
his roles in Rogue one the Clone Wars
and Star Wars Rebels Guerrera is just as
intense a manic as ever Lutheran rail
journeys to his remote base to discuss a
potential alliance with soar but his
suggestion is rejected the two men's
conversation is quite revealing Saul
complains that the many different Rebel
factions including separatists
neo-republicans the Gorman fronts and
the partisans are too different in their
beliefs to be unified Lutheran begs to
differ the discussion sheds new light in
the significance of the original
trilogy's Rebel Alliance and how
difficult it was to bring it together
eagle-eyed viewers will recognize a
mercenary benthic two tubes a longtime
Ally of guerreras standing watch over
the base as Lutheran lands you might
also notice the X-Wing style fighter
parked behind him though Rogue Squadron
as we know it may yet be a ways off from
forming it's good to know that the
rebels most famous ship is already
getting some use
indoor episode 9 reveals that the
rebellious valsatha leader of the aldani
heist is mon mothma's cousin while both
women know of each other's illicit
activities they clearly don't share
specifics for instance when mon asvel
something about Lutheran she acts like
she doesn't know what a cousin is
talking about that secrecy is a glimpse
into the divisions of the early
rebellion and their conversation
features a couple of especially
interesting details for one thing Vel
repeats the same dogmatic phrase her
lover Center says to her in episode 8.
The Rebellion comes first
we take what's left
come on it might sound like a cousin's
loyalty to the cause is stronger than
ever but the knowledge of Val's
conversation with sinser reveals another
layer velas had multiple doubts about
her Rebel work and her use of sinta's
exact words show how hard she's trying
to convince herself of its worth it also
shows how much she misses Center who
never seemed to share vel's misgivings
at the same time mon seems to both
admire and fear for her cousin she sees
her right after a senate session that
seems to sour quickly as mon delivers an
impassioned speech about the Empire's
overreach of power she's met with some
support but mostly with apathy
Cassian spends most of the season's
ninth episode trying to get to its floor
manager Kino Loy to give him some
information about the prison he asked
him repeatedly how many guards are on
each floor but Loy refuses to tell him
in many ways Kino represents what the
Empire is trying to do to the Galaxy
forcing cooperation by breaking the
spirit even though Kino has to work 12
hours a day and eat food that comes out
of a tube he would rather keep his head
down than make waves after all his own
sentence will be up soon right that's
just to do things the right way of
course everything changes when Kino
learns that prisoners are simply being
moved to New floors of facilities after
their sentences are supposedly up in the
final moments of the episode Kino
realizes that there truly Is No Escape
unless he makes one he immediately
starts telling Cassian everything he
knows about the prison this Sudden
Change proves Lutheran rail's theory he
tells more mothma in an earlier episode
that oppression breeds Rebellion show
people a clear way out without having to
fight and many will take it he argues
but but if you show people that there's
no way out they'll have no choice but to
take up arms that's exactly what Kino
seems primed to do
most of Andor episode 10 is spent on the
Kina 5 but there is a brief scene at the
ISB where major partagas gets briefed on
the agency's plan to trap a rebel cell
led by the enigmatic Anto Krieger the
ISB had captured a rebel pilot from
Krieger cell but released him back into
space dead in a malfunctioning ship to
assuage any concerns from the rebel
leader that the Empire might be onto his
plans patergas is informed that the ship
has been located as planned by caffeine
rescue Salvage a mining Outpost and
commerce Hub Catherine is where Cassian
first appears in Rogue one he follows up
a lead with a rebel contact there but
ends up killing the contact to secure
his Escape that escape is crucial as the
information he gets on Catherine
concerns the Death Star itself it
doesn't seem like the inclusion of
Catherine and Andor is of too much
specific importance but it is a nice bit
of connective tissue
and or episode 10 ends with a powerful
exchange between Luther and Rael and
Lani young his mole in the ISB we
learned that Lani has been periodically
given Lutheran information about
Imperial operations and that Lutheran
has shared some secrets about the rebels
to avoid suspicion when Lonnie says he
wants out Lutheran was spawned for the
powerful monologue listing all the
things he's given up to fight the Empire
I burned my decency for someone else's
future I burned my life to make a
sunrise that I know I'll Never See
it's a deeply affecting speech and this
magnified all the more by Lutheran's
Outfit Black robes beneath a flowing
black cave standing in the shadows of
the corridor he could easily be mistaken
for a Sith Lord the dark Hue of his
clothes is a far cry from the bright
white to the prison outfits of nakina 5
which themselves represent the heroes
Lutheran says he's looking for he
understands that his role in the
Rebellion is to take on all the moral
corruption so that others might fly
higher and do real good
as Lutheran rail gives his closing
monologue in The Season's 10th episode
he mentions the heroes of the Rebellion
a group among which he doesn't count
himself but which he hopes will grow as
we hear his words we see Cassian
escaping over the barren land of nakina
5 with ruskart melshi one of his fellow
escapees everyone knows that Cassian
becomes a rebel hero but melshi also
does big things in the fight against the
empire malshi is first introduced in
Rogue one where he fights side by side
with Cassian during the Battle of scarif
like the rest of the Rogue one team he
ends up making the ultimate sacrifice to
ensure that the rebels obtain the Death
Star plans a shot of melshi and Andor
escaping is a bit of Hope in a dark
moment an assurance that Lutheran's
reprehensible Deeds eventually become
worth it he lays the groundwork for the
heroes who eventually bring about the
death star's destruction which in turn
allows Rebellion the opportunity to
defeat Palpatine's regime for good
the end of the 11th episode of Andor
sees Luther and rail caught in a tricky
situation involving an Imperial cruiser
but not one we've gotten to see in much
detail before his ship's computer
identifies the vessel a variant of a
star destroyer with a long thin nose and
three massive tractor beam dishes as a
cantwell-class cruiser this ship has a
long and storied history in the Star
Wars Universe the ship is named after
real-life concept artists and all-around
sci-fi Legend Colin Cantwell who passed
away in May of 2022 Cantwell provided
some of the first designs for iconic
ships including the X-Wing and Tie
Fighter he also provided concepts for
the Imperial Star Destroyer which
initially bore the look of what's now
become the cantwell-class cruiser an
artist writer and engineer among other
things Cantwell worked with NASA and on
other major genre films like Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 A Space Odyssey its
initial design for the Stardust Joya was
meant to appear in Solo a Star Wars
story but the scene featuring it
prominently was curse you given how much
kanswell contributes it to the Star Wars
Universe it's nice to see his original
designer appear with such a Grandeur in
Andor
in the season finale the night before
Marva andor's funeral on ferricks
Deirdre Miro arrives via Lambda class
Imperial shuttle the stark white design
of the ship has been iconic since its
debut in the original trilogy and it
looks just as austere as ever here
standing out against the planet's night
sky like a stormtrooper against a brick
wall daedra's shuttle isn't the only
familiar Imperial ship in the scene
however NASA transport touches down we
can see another shuttle parked on an
adjacent landing pad with four thin
Wings pointing up to the sky this second
shuttle a Zeta class is the same model
as the one used by Cassian and Jin urso
in Rogue one stolen from the Empire the
zeta-class shuttle becomes a flagship of
the Rogue one Squad since the vessel is
a pretty standard cargo ship used for
transporting troops in cargo his
presence on ferex shouldn't raise any
eyebrows but his inclusion also feels
like an intentional nod toward cassian's
future marva's funeral ends up being a
pivotal moment in both ferric's
resistance against the empire and
cassian's own internal Arc by the end of
the season finale he has fully given
himself to the rebel course and the ship
glimpsed in his early shot to Marx
apathy's now headed down
in The Season's third episode Marva
gives a warning to some of the corporate
cops who come to ferricks looking for
Cassian as the strange insistent Rhythm
of the town's Chimes keep ringing the
men get unnerved but Marvel tells them
but when it stops
that's when you really want to start to
fret
in the season finale this warning comes
full circle at Marvel's own funeral the
funeral procession includes a full band
which plays a slow somber song as they
March toward the Town Square and the
Imperial forces stationed there at one
point the whole parade stops and the
music goes silent only for it to come
back stronger seconds later in a faster
more aggressive tune then the Music
Stops entirely for Marvel's final
hologram speech leading to the battle
between the locals and their oppressors
it plays out just as Marvel warned so
it's only fitting that this is how
she'll be remembered
in a somewhat surprising move season one
of Andor ends with a brief post-credits
scene after seeing Cassian commit to the
rebel course and watching the first
batch of credits roll viewers are
treated to what appears to be droids
constructing something as the camera
zooms out it's revealed that what's
being built as part of the Death Star
super laser and the real kicker is that
the droids are building it using the
large cog-like pieces that Cassian and
his fellow inmates were forced to
construct a narkina 5. some fans guessed
this development prior to the season
finale but seeing the battle station in
its near full glory is still an
effective moment it's both a reminder of
where cassion is headed and a grim
picture of what the Empire is doing to
the Galaxy the fact that the prisoners
of nakina 5 were being made to build a
weapon that would threaten the entire
galaxy is perverse and it emphasizes
that Palpatine views his citizens simply
as cheap labor for evil schemes of
course there's also a bit of Triumph in
the post-credits scene it conjures
images of cassian's ultimate victory
over the Death Star and the empire even
the prison break on the akina 5 can be
seen as an act that unintentionally
stalls the development of the battle
situation possibly granting the extra
time necessary for the operation in
Rogue one to work
[Music]